[Music]
Give back the princess,
Princess Zion. Oh yeah, I fell from the carriage into the river. That's how the
princess turned out. I read it in an Ellis novel. The
prince tried to bring back the breath of a drowning person. I'm
sure. I didn't expect this to be
a kiss.  I had decided that my first partner would be Prince Abel,
but when a
person who was drowning in Sinkland-style human breathing turned his head to
the side and
made noises with his fingers, he
tried to suck Prince Sion's mouth.  Thanks to appropriate measures, Mi's
first kiss was saved safely.I'm glad I was able to
blow it back.I
thought I was going to die.That torrent
was certainly dangerous.DET